[Music]
we can use
technology to make finance more
inclusive and more accessible
to many more millions of people in our
country and many more hundreds of
millions of people around the globe
today on chalk radio modern money
in this episode we're taking a look at
15 soa
fintech shaping the financial world this
is a course about money
and how it works in a constantly
changing digital environment
my research and teaching is all about
the intersection between
finance and technology and what better
place to do it but at mit
our guest today is professor gary
gensler he co-directs mit's fintech at
csail
which stands for computer science and ai
lab
professor gensler has a unique
perspective
in that he's teaching a subject that's
continuously evolving
so how does an educator teach something
that changes so much
and so rapidly how do you prepare
students to work in a new
and oftentimes vastly different context
one that literally
might not even exist yet but before we
dive into all of that
we first have to understand what is
fintech
this term fintech which came about in
the last
20 or so years can mean different things
to different
folks for me i think of it if
how's finance changing due to new
technologies and the original fintech
was
money itself invented thousands of years
ago by humans
but usually a lot of folks these days
will call
fintech the companies that are
disrupting the world of finance using
machine
learning or using something called
blockchain technology
but 20 years ago it would be correct to
say that
what technology was disrupting finance
more than anything else was the internet
and 10 or 15 years ago the technology
that was disrupting
finance the most was mobile phones and
cloud
and so i teach it from a broader view
and try to prepare students with this
concept so they're ready for the 2030s
and the 2040s what
technologies then will be highly
disruptive in finance
it's really about how technology is
changing the world of finance and
has for centuries and will for centuries
to come
and right now we're living through this
transitional period
of machine learning artificial
intelligence
internet of things blockchain technology
and a decade from now it will be some
other transition
and so i really try to engage the
students on what that means what those
big technology movements mean
as they come into the technology stack
and then they just become accepted
[Music]
in helping me understand what fintech
actually is
professor gensler made some really
interesting observations about the way
we use money now
versus even just 10 years ago and what
that implies about where we're headed
that which we call money that which
plato and aristotle called money was
just
a society's representation of something
of value
but boy in the 21st century aren't we
there
that you can just wave your mobile phone
and
you move value what we call money the
greatest changes of the early 2020s
is about two forms of artificial
intelligence
one is machine learning machine learning
has a remarkable ability to
to extract correlations and data where
we couldn't find it earlier
with earlier forms of math linear
algebra
and so forth and the second form of
artificial intelligence that's
dramatically changing finance
is natural language processing what do
these words mean they're just kind of
fancy words to say
can you move human language to computer
language
and guess what all day long that's
happening and we're starting to get robo
advice
and robo advisory platforms
can deliver finance far more broadly
to four more people so bank of america
has
its voice assistant erica but millions
of their customers are now using
erica to do modest transactions move
bank balances around things like that so
we
try in the classroom to think about this
with students
and sort of prepare them what are the
next technologies not just the
technologies like machine learning and
natural language processing
but what are the next technologies and
how do we think of
entrepreneurial strategy how to think of
the strategy
to use new technologies to provide
services
and in the classic way that you always
have to think about
as an entrepreneur how can you do
something better quicker cheaper
that's not been done today during my
conversation with professor genzler
i began to realize how far-reaching the
implications of fintech can be
expanding access to financial literacy
is a really important outcome
that drives his teaching and his passion
for the work
what i was drawn to mit about was this
sense that maybe we could democratize
capitalism a bit more that
we can use technology to make
finance more inclusive and more
accessible to many more millions of
people in our country and many more
hundreds of millions of people around
the globe
new technologies come along every decade
or so
and then they disrupt this status quo
and what's really exciting is at mit
we're at the forefront of those new
technologies
and we can bring those practices those
new practices into the classroom and say
well now what's this doing
to finance what does it mean that a big
technology company
is starting to have a credit card maybe
what does it mean that apple credit card
exists or
facebook wants to have a worldwide
currency called libra
or that we might provide insurance
that's going to be measuring
our fitbits or watches or our mobile
devices
as to whether we're healthy or not
students from all areas of mit sloan
school of management
and even students registered from other
schools flocked professor genzler's
class to learn more about what the
future of finance looks like
and how they might help shape it
students come into this class
for multiple purposes but i'd say the
majority
are really interested how
these new technologies might be
disrupting
a big part of an economy and the
students are from
all over the globe and dominantly
they're thinking about
i want to understand how this technology
is disrupting finance
so i asked all the students to write a
memo
a clearly worded recommendation memo
but their recommendation they can pick
one of three ceos
jeff bezos of amazon brian moynihan who
runs bank of america
or mark andreessen who runs a big
venture capital firm
andreessen horowitz and i said you
picked whether you want to write about
the provision of credit the provision of
credit cards provision of automobile
insurance the provision of mortgages you
pick whatever you want to pick
in finance but you have to write a ceo
recommendation member with a clearly
stated recommendation
to amazon bank of america or andreessen
horowitz
and a little over half the students pick
amazon they're all really
interesting memos to read and the
students engage
they engage because there there's
tremendous benefit
to giving students a real live thing to
address that it's a real live
thing where i say listen if this is a
great memo
i'll figure out the way to get it to
jeff bezos i'll figure out the way to
get it to brian moynihan and the
students believe me because
i i could get a really great memo to
them
some students will say can i write it to
somebody in brazil instead and i always
say yes
you know had a great memo to the
ceo of tension the big technology
network in china
and it was one of the best memos this
group of students put together
i would say to elder educators trust the
students
if you give them a little bit of an open
ended
prompt like this a big majority will
rise to the occasion
as is the case with most things nowadays
professor gentzler's course is formatted
a little differently in the time of
cobit 19
but he's seen some pretty remarkable
results at achieving
some semblance of normalcy in his new
class format
we're in very unusual times that those
of us who
learned our teaching skills in the
classroom with
with anywhere from you know 15 to 100
students in the class that you were all
having a shared experience
all of a sudden with a snap of a finger
were online
most of us at sloan felt it was really
important to keep
some sense of community and so when
i started the first class online
i asked all the students
those that could to listen
together synchronously and so
this class was taught at 8 30 to 10 a.m
on monday and wednesday
and so for many time zones at work but
did it really work for somebody sitting
in europe who might be
had flown back so we did record it
but we got about 85 to 90 of the
students
tying in synchronously and i felt it was
not only important that it was
synchronous but
secondly that everyone had their video
on
and i would tell the students i said i
know that you might have a
friend a spouse a lover a child
walk through the camera you might have a
delivery which
one day i was teaching and i had a
delivery and there was a pounding on the
door
i had to say to the students excuse me i
have to go to the door
but i said that's life we just we're
going to relax about all of this
but i felt it formed a better sense of
community
[Music]
before teaching at mit professor gensler
cut his teeth in the professional and
political world
working for goldman sachs the us
department of treasury
hillary clinton's campaign paul sarbanes
in the u.s senate
and with barack obama's administration
chairing something called the commodity
futures trading commission
his understanding of what makes a
successful well-equipped professional
shines through in his classes kenzler
isn't just developing domain knowledge
but cultivating humans and professionals
i want to read something to you that
you've written oh my god here's the
embarrassing moment
no it's good um it says respect and
courtesy
build reputations networks and trust
that seems important in your teaching so
i'm wondering how your focus
on helping students cultivate
professionalism
kind of plays out in the course how do
you teach
that so i think that each of us that
walk into a classroom
have a big responsibility it's such a
privilege to be at mit with this
incredible student body
and faculty and staff but i feel that we
have this responsibility that goes
beyond
our domain knowledge of course i'm in
the classroom teaching
finance and technology in this
intersection of how
machine learning and blockchain
technology
and internet of things is changing the
world of finance
but i also think that when i look back
at the faculty members i learned the
most from
when i went i went to wharton it was not
about the domain knowledge of accounting
or finance or linear algebra or biology
it was more about values it was more
about
professionalism and i've been honored to
work at very high levels of
professionalism
often the race goes to the person who's
prepped the most
who's been courteous who listens as much
as they talk
who ask questions that are relevant
and i come back to that not just in the
classroom
but i offer lunches to the students and
i
they sign up an open sign up forum where
up to eight students can sign
up and i usually do this in person
but what i found in this covered
time there was such a demand that i set
up lunches twice a week
all through the six weeks and they were
nearly always booked with eight students
and and we would just have no agenda
other than we would talk about
careers and professionalism and the like
so maybe for some small percentage of
the students
it will stick and then i usually end my
last lecture in every one of my classes
and i
i do a quote from benjamin franklin
and benjamin franklin believe it or not
spoke about money
so i figure it's i get i get a little
bit of a
pass if i get hokey on the last day
and i bring benjamin franklin in this
wonderful
warm quote that you can look up about
benjamin franklin and money but what he
really is talking about is paying it
forward he talks about if you
should should uh somebody does you a
favor
the way that you repay the favor is
doing the favor to others
and he says this is the best form of
money he knows
to re do a favor by paying it back to
others
i feel that those of us who are
privileged to be in these positions
if we can share that and it sticks with
some percentage of the students
that's as important maybe more important
than the domain
knowledge and the domain analysis
i mean i like to think we teach a lot
more than knowledge that we teach a way
of thinking
if you're ready to learn more about
fintech you can visit professor
gensler's course materials on our mit
open courseware website and if you're an
educator who reuses the materials in
your own teaching
call or write to us to share your story
you'll help inspire others
thank you so much for listening and if
you like what you've heard so far
please consider leaving us a review
wherever you're listening to this
podcast today
signing off from cambridge massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen
from mit courseware
mom pass the car